sigamos hablando del trabajo como un
factor de producción y en particular
analizaremos la curva de oferta de
trabajo cuando pensamos en la oferta o
la demanda de trabajo podemos ver la
cantidad como las horas trabajadas en
cierto periodo de tiempo y podemos ver
el precio del trabajo como los salarios
y podemos pensar en cómo se verá la
curva de demanda de trabajo cuando los
salarios son altos no muchas personas
querrán contratar trabajo porque es muy
caro y quizá no lo puedan pagar conforme
disminuyen los salarios más personas
demandarán ese trabajo por lo que
querrán que las personas trabajen más
horas
esta es la curva de demanda de trabajo
y que hay con la curva de oferta de
trabajo como creen que se vea bueno
cuando los salarios son bajos muchas
personas pueden decir que tienen cosas
mejores que hacer con su tiempo pero
conforme aumentan los salarios pueden
cambiar estas otras cosas por un salario
más alto en hacer las otras cosas puede
tener un mayor costo de oportunidad y
volverse más caras por lo que pueden
cambiar esas cosas por el trabajo por lo
que colectivamente pueden trabajar más
horas de manera que conforme aumentan
los salarios también aumentan en general
las horas trabajadas
así nos queda una curva de oferta
clásica es la curva de oferta de trabajo
y esta dinámica que acabo de comentar en
la que las personas eligen el trabajar o
el hacer otras cosas se conoce
típicamente como la elección trabajo
ocio en el lenguaje cotidiano cuando
usamos la palabra ocio nos referimos al
tiempo en que nos relajamos o la pasamos
con los amigos o nos divertimos en algo
pero en economía al hablar de la
elección trabajo ocio se refieren ya sea
al trabajo
oa cualquier cosa que no sea trabajo por
lo que ocio también incluye el dormir o
el comer o ir al baño todo esto se
incluye por lo que debería llamarse
elección trabajo no trabajo pero imagino
que no suena tan bien como elección
trabajo ocio lo que vemos que ocurre
aquí es que conforme aumentan los
salarios las personas están dispuestas a
cambiar el ocio entre comillas por el
trabajo ahora el efecto del que hablamos
y que tiene que ver con el sentido común
se llama efecto sustitución conforme
aumentan los salarios podemos ver que el
costo de oportunidad del ocio se vuelve
cada vez más caro y si algo se vuelve
más caro
tratamos de sustituirlo por otra cosa en
este caso se sustituye con trabajo hay
una dinámica interesante de la que
hablan algunas personas se llama el
efecto ingreso y esto se refiere a que
conforme aumentan los salarios uno
tiende a comprar o demandar más de todo
y podemos ver al ocio como un bien que
uno como trabajador puede querer esta
dinámica se refiere a que si el ingreso
alcanza cierto nivel entonces uno ya no
querrá trabajar más y querrá más ocio
porque tenemos más que suficiente para
cubrir todas nuestras necesidades
si queremos imaginar cómo se ve una
curva de la oferta en donde imaginamos
que existe el efecto ingreso en los
salarios más altos
podemos verlo así en salarios bajos es
muy parecido a lo que describimos
anteriormente pero hay un salario en
donde las personas dicen bueno creo que
tengo suficiente dinero así que en lugar
de trabajar esa hora extra prefiero
pasar esa hora con mi familia o salir a
distraerme en mi opinión pienso que esta
es una mentalidad bastante sana aunque
quizá muchas personas no estén de
acuerdo pero si este fuera el caso al
llegar a cierto salario las personas
podrían querer trabajar menos por lo que
veríamos esta parte que se dobla para
regresar en la curva de oferta de
trabajo
esta es la curva de oferta de trabajo
con el efecto ingreso después de cierto
punto esto es algo interesante para
pensar existe cierto nivel de salario en
el que las personas dicen
ya tengo suficiente y en lugar de
trabajar más duro quizá quieran trabajar
menos esto es interesante para pensar